yo looking for the champ
chance here champs here what's up
brother how are you good man how about
you I'm doing good man congratulations
thank you bro thank you so much
how you feeling today well bust it up
you know what uh feeling good yeah
yeah man here's a bunch of bumps and
bruises when you fight like that for 25
minutes with these caliber of guys you
got hit in spots you didn't even know
you got hit in Europe yeah I guess it
doesn't really feel like a massage does
it how are you celebrating man dude I'm
not really doing a whole lot honestly I
uh took my daughter to the zoo today
that's about it really
yeah does she know that uh does she know
that that uh is a champion yeah I do she
knows man and it makes me feel so good
that's awesome yeah like she calls a
belt the belt you know she said that
daddy so every time she walks by she
points to his daddy's belly so pretty if
she likes it she loves it okay Batman
now do you find yourself recovering or
do you find yourself like thinking about
training like what kind of like what's
going on like in is sort of in your head
a little in that stuff right now like
I'm just kind of seeing what uh pains
gonna stay longer than a few days what
what's not and uh you know get what
what's not going to go away in a few
days I'll get it checked out by a doctor
get some MRIs done but I feel pretty
pretty healthy and then I kind of the
good thing about this fight is I know my
next step for the most of my career I
didn't know the next step after fights
now we know we're gonna fight could be
to unify the belts oh and he's suspended
until September I believe so I know I'm
probably not gonna fight until September
so that gives me like a little peace of
mind that a fights not gonna pop up on
me I can kind of start planning
accordingly to that timeline yeah
now do you would that happen in
September or do you it could happen
after that do you have a say-so in that
how does that kind of work no I believe
it's meat you know a cabeza undisputed
champ so him in the UFC I guess are
going to figure it out but his
suspension ends I believe in September
so that doesn't mean he can't start a
training camp before then you know he
can be ready to go as soon as that the
data suspension ends so and that's what
I've heard floating around that that
September is the date they're gonna plan
the next fight Wow wow man um are you
worried about like I know a lot of these
fighters or it seems like I'm learning
anyway that a lot of a lot of the
fighters like as they you know once you
become a champion once you get a belt
that a lot of the media obligations
become more pertinent especially and
more just you have a lot more
obligations to the media around fight
time and that it can drain a lot of
Fighters do you worry about any of that
I don't really like think about it that
much that can worry about it but now
that you're mentioning a bro this last
fight that lead-up to this last fight I
mean I was non-stop interviews non-stop
going to different places on fight week
which I usually don't you know that's
new to me every now and then on a fight
we got go to like a radio station here
and there but this time my whole
itinerary was just full of interviews
and places to be it made the week fly by
really but it is a distraction and a
little bit of stress yeah did um you you
said in an interview Dustin man that
just one of the neatest things I've ever
heard and you said 25 minutes to make
life fair can you tell me a little bit
about that yeah brother uh Teddy yeah I
was listening to a podcast when a Teddy
Atlas podcast don't know if you know
Teddy Atlas is he's a legendary boxing
trainer been around a long time was one
of the first guys to train Mike Tyson Oh
under custom motto just a very very
interesting mind in combat sports when I
was two the guy talked like you know you
just very well spoken about about
feelings and things that fighters go
through and stuff but on this podcast he
was talking about no other time in life
or in history do you have an opportunity
to raise your arms up in the air and
because the best in the world
champion of the world no matter what
it's accept infighting you know and
that's what I was looking at coming into
this fight is twenty five minutes no
matter I said I've lost in the past
what the oddsmakers say people who told
me I'm not good enough oh you know just
every time I've slipped and fell or
every critic out there every opinion out
there I had twenty five minutes to mute
that out yeah and and and in my own
hands I had control of my destiny and I
knew I had it for 25 minutes and that
was very powerful going into that fight
just knowing that and I wanted to leave
all of myself out there give it my all
and whatever was going to happen was
going to happen but I walked into the
cage that night comfortable knowing that
I was prepared to do everything that I
had physically you know everything
possible of myself I was willing to do
it whatever it took to win that belt and
make life fair for twenty five minutes
man Wow
you mean you hit the ring you were just
you were feeling good that James Brown
hit the scene man it was uh God that was
live man when now when you're backstage
the fight before you guys was Jesus
Christ man were you watching that I was
also there stairs in the locker room
where you warm up there's a big mat you
know to warm up on him stuff and there's
a TV there streaming the fights live so
you kind of know where you're at you
know I know how was the main event so
the co-main is going I can write when it
ends I know I have about five or six
minutes where they come give me and say
okay you're good you're walking now so I
was kind of keeping an eye on it but I
didn't get to see every round you know I
was warming up and kind of just glancing
at it so I need to go back and watch it
I haven't yet man it was powerful I mean
it was just at that point yeah we're
just like I'm sitting there in the
stands like Jesus I can't imagine that
there's gonna be more fighting like it
was just those guys had murdered each
other dude how I mean interview you how
was your first trip to a fight oh it was
scary man I was swinging my own I almost
knocked my date at one time
so that was kind of alarming how what
meant it was uh it gave me a whole
different respect for for uh for
fighters like even just a minute ago
when you said that they come and walk
you from the back out there five minutes
up that to me feels like an electric
chair like they would be walking me like
dead man walking you know like to the
last moment to be honest with you and
you know uh fighting everybody thinks
guys are tough guys you know I'm a bad
dude for sure I can fight I'm one of the
best in the world and I know like what
I'm capable of but I'm not immune to
those feelings I'm scared to death back
there even though I'm so prepared and
and you know put in so many years and
months into this single training camp
like this one guy well there's still the
under unknown out there I don't
anything could happen I know I'm human
if I make a mistake and get kneed in the
face I know I'll get knocked out right
so you know we're in a weird way as they
come get you and say I like Dustin
you're walking it's almost you feel like
you're being led I don't want to say
it's a slaughter but you're being led to
a crowd full of people and you're about
to step in the in the you know in an
arena and frickin you know it feels like
you're going out there to fight to the
death that's what it feels like to me
Wow
does it um is there uh can you feel the
crowd when you're out there or is are
you just so you guys are just so zoned
in to what you're doing you know earlier
in my career I could uh everything was
muted out it was just how so much
adrenaline pounding that I could only
just react and do what I was doing but
now as I've got so many fights under my
belt I can hear everything then yeah
it's so interesting man it's like if
it's like it's like Christmas but
Santa's like trying to beat the [__] out
of you you know that's what it kind of
was like the vibe that it kind of seemed
from me like if I was a I can only
imagine if I was in your shoes it would
be like so exciting because you're ready
it's there you've been waiting for it
but then you gotta like you know Santa's
not bringing gifts dude he's bringing an
ass-whooping you know right right he's
[__] mad
and his man it is kinda like that you're
so excited you're like anxious to
perform you've been working you want
everybody to see what level you're
capable of fighting at you want to show
everything you're you know yeah I've
been working on but at the same time
it's still like oh my god we're doing
this and we're fighting anything could
happen oh but that's like when you're
when you're a young fighter you don't
think about those things I think those
are things that come along with time and
maturity in the sport like when I was
young I never thought about that you
know the possibility of getting hit in
the elbow and split in the face or
knocked out I didn't think about those
things I was just going out there to
fight but as you get older you're like
okay you know you've seen some things
and Vincent places you like this a
dangerous man right this is dangerous
now a lot of these guys so you know that
you're gonna have this next fight
against khabib it's not for certain yet
but it's close
yeah man you know nothing's for certain
mixed martial arts nothing surprises me
anymore I don't know but I don't know
what's gonna happen but the the plan is
to unify the boss
Dana told me that Dana's publicly said
it and you know that's what I think
should happen yeah yeah do you worry
about a lot of those guys from certain
parts of the world you know and I'm not
naming any but like Dagestan you know
they use like performance-enhancing
drugs and stuff do you worry about that
kind of thing you know you saw it was
pretty pretty tight man we were Olympic
drug tested year round by you sada hmm
just as well just this last week in
Atlanta I was tested twice my own urine
Tesla one blood test and I was only
there for five days so you know they do
very strenuous testing year-round so I
think they cleaned up the sport you know
I just I just hope they it's an even
playing field you know that's right oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah you want it to be
fair yeah they I woulda tested positive
for being a straight [__] and the
audience do it I was like it's so scared
for us some people got hurt I was
praying for people I texted the police
at one point like it was getting uh it
was crazy man it was so crazy man just
dude I would think and there were
certain moment trials I caught just get
to the end of the round and then you
have to [__] do another round
dude I know I know manic when I last
when v on came out for my fight when I
got off the stool I was [__] excited I
was like alright now I can just do it
out you know I could leave everything
out of there I don't have to conserve I
don't have to worry about anything we
got five minutes left to find out was
the best that was exciting time you know
knowing there's five minutes left in
this battle
yeah it seemed like um I mean you just
came outside
dude I woke up in the middle of the
night and watch the whole fight last
night on YouTube again and yet it's so
much different watching it in person
it's so much more intense than watching
it on television or on tape that's what
that's what that's that's what I try to
tell people who've never been to a live
event like watching even boxing any
combat sport watching it on TV you can
hear the punches land but you don't get
the impact feeling and you don't feel
the energy when you're in there
especially how close you are man you
were down there commentating the fights
and yeah just feel the the energy and
the force and you can see the aggression
and the sweat and blood flying it's just
a totally different feel watching fights
that close Bronski suddenly I got scared
again right now yeah it was uh it was
everything man and seeing when you got
that belt man that's how yeah I mean
just paid in full man it just it you
could just see it you could just see it
all right there for you man that must
have just been what was it like it was
uh you know all these years I imagined
getting the belt put on me and imagine
just touching the belt and being a
champion in the UFC but when it actually
happened it was uh it felt like a dream
it's not better than I can even I could
ever thought it felt like and it felt
right it didn't you know it felt like I
earned it there's no like 12 years of
work and and it just really felt good
man I've never felt anything like that I
just felt really accomplished and just
proud of myself you know hey man what
else well I mean it's your journey you
know and I think those are perfect that
seems to be yeah you felt very
accomplished it felt right and it's
interesting that you say it felt like a
dream because it was a this was a dream
of yours so it's like it would almost
make sense that it felt that way I guess
you know right and a dream at times that
has slipped away from me and I didn't
know if I was gonna
no I just in the back of my head always
like no matter what happened I'm gonna
push through it and overcome and just
have perseverance through anything but
you know still some some days are tough
man some days on the job are tough I've
lost big big fights in the past and
going back home after losing a big fight
it's like man will I ever really make
this a reality and do it when it go and
touch my skin man I just do like all
those years bro
all those years yeah it's so interesting
man I gotta actually got a message from
Michael Bisping the other night and he
said man he did it you know because I've
been messaging him the week before just
asking about the fights and and no one
it seems I was looking at some
information online and it said that no
one has had a longer route from their
first fight to a belt than Bisping had
26 fights and I guess for you it was 22
and and he said a couple nice things
just such supportive things that he
could really relate to your journey man
do you feel like the journey is over
where do you find motivation and
inspiration now no no you know what I
have is a piece of the World
Championship I have to unify the bow it
could be when I could win that beat
could be then I'm on top of the mountain
you know right now I'm on I'm on the
edge I got I got a few more steps to go
once I beat khabib then then I'm on top
of the mountain and then it becomes
about legacy you know what can i what
can I do differently than these other
champions yeah can I do the separate
myself in that category there's levels
to it man there's levels to it for sure
yeah but you're a champion man and
that's and they can never take it away
from you man
congratulations so much and tell me
about your organization when we're time
Dustin that you have there and Lafayette
not a Coconut Creek yeah yeah me and my
wife have the good fight foundation it's
the good fight group calm if you want
any info but uh we're just doing things
around Acadiana and southern Louisiana
trying to help out trying to use my
platform in the best way I can to make
people you know better in my community
to better the everything we can do you
know we're not set to one specific goal
we do all types of things but this next
goal we have we're building a playground
for disabled children at an elementary
school and
really really excited to do that that's
awesome and we're gonna go online and
make a make a donation right after this
and and and yeah man it'd be great if
you and I know you know I've talked
about over the past year about doing
maybe a comedy show and doing some
fundraising efforts together down there
and in south Louisiana and and if you're
still willing to do that man I'd love to
be able to you know for us to see that
see that to fruition
oh I'm 100% down I can start working on
it if you want to man it'll be great I
think you can really have a huge turnout
and we can get some some good stuff
going for Louisiana yeah I think so too
man we could start local I love it uh
the champ do congratulations brother
thank you do man it was awesome to see
you out there in the crowd bro dude I
was so excited for I was gonna [__] it
if anybody jumped in I was jumping in
you know you know I I know you had my
back okay look I was gonna get knocked
the [__] out boy I was ready to get
knocked out I even brought a pillow in
my bag so I was ready man
congratulations champion joy your time
with your family thank you so much the
old brother good to hear from you are
you too man have a good day yeah